it's well known that some British
tabloid newspapers hacked into the cell
phones of celebrities members of the
royal family and others then published
their personal information there have
been several convictions in recent years
with newspapers paying out tens of
millions of dollars to victims but now
Prince Harry has launched three new
legal cases against the UK's powerful
tabloid newspapers over phone hacking
with allegations dating back to the
1990s
Piers Morgan is the former editor of one
of the papers accused I'm not going to
take lectures on privacy Invasion from
Prince Harry somebody spent the last
three years ruthlessly and cynically
invading the Royal Family's privacy for
vast commercial gain in legal documents
the family have avoided going to court
because they don't want to testify about
issues that may be embarrassing